[MUSIC].
And we're back at the Udacity Sense Olympics. Andy, can you give us an overview
of what's been going on?
&gt;&gt; Yeah. So, we've had four events so far. And in this first event, we found that
our contestants could only detect a difference in weight of about 3%. In the
second, our contestants identified the five primary flavors. And in these last
two events, we discovered or pushed the limits of the thresholds of human
hearing. What we learn is that humans can really hear between 20 and 20,000 Hz
and that the quietest sound we can hear is about 0 dB.
&gt;&gt; Well, Andy, somethings been bothering me. How exactly does hearing work?
&gt;&gt; What do you mean by that? That's a pretty big question.
&gt;&gt; Well, okay, so I know sound vibrates the air but once those vibrations get into
my ear, how do I perceive that sound?
&gt;&gt; That's, that's a really good question. And actually, the transduction of a
sound wave to a perceived sound is a pretty complicated process.